[Musique]
maintenant je veux que tu te reposes bien et
s'ils ont un mauvais rêve, je suis sûr que nous pouvons
gérer n'importe quel rêve que tu as et si je
rêve que tu nous as renvoyés dans le
noir et que j'ai vraiment mal ce que j'ai  Je suis si
triste j'ai peur du noir là-bas alors j'ai
pris du poison en moi pendant des années et des années
jusqu'à ce que mon sang se transforme en poison et que mon
cœur se brise en deux et que je ne puisse
rien ressentir de heureux
[Musique]
Je ne peux pas le supporter  plus une nuit ils
doivent mourir
à temps sur une table en argent
c'est ma mâchoire fermée
[Musique]
nous avez-vous réveillés d'un rêve comme
ça
nous ne sommes pas comme n'importe quelle autre famille nous sommes
différents à
cause de l'endroit où nous avons grandi
Hill  Maison
ta mère elle n'était pas folle
ni sa sœur ni ton
frère ni toi
c'est cette maison